(pleasant piano music)
- [Narrator] California's iconic sequoias
are the largest trees on Earth.
These giants have lived
for thousands of years,
surviving war, famine and
the rise of globalization,
but California's ongoing
drought could mean disaster.
These enormous trees are already
showing signs of weakness
never seen before.
Anthony Ambrose and a team of researchers
are heading into the forest
to climb hundreds of feet in the air
and see what can be done to
save these magnificent trees.
(dramatic music)
- Our research entails climbing
the giant sequoia trees
and measuring their water status,
basically an index of
how stressed they are
relative to the environment.
The water status of all plants
is kind of like the equivalent
of blood pressure in a human.
It's just a basic measure
of how much water they have
available to them to
continue to function and grow
so we clip little shoots of foliage
and we put the little piece
of foliage leaf end down
into this pressurized chamber
and the amount of
pressure it takes to push
the water back out of the stem
is equal to the amount
of tension it was under
when you cut that piece of foliage.
When water availability declines,
such as during a drought,
that creates a lot more
tension in the tree.
When the tension becomes too great,
then tiny little air
bubbles form in the wood
and when it gets bad enough
then the plant suffers and starts to die.
(gentle piano music)
There's a couple reasons
why we need to climb
to the tops of these trees.
As water moves up the tree,
it's fighting gravity and friction
and the top of the tree is gonna be
the most stressed part of the tree.
So, in order to get a really good idea
of how stressed they are,
we need to go to the very tippy top.
It's a real humbling experience
because you're up in the crown
of these massive, ancient things
and they make you feel small.
I'm at the top of a very
large, giant sequoia tree
waiting for the sunrise
'cause it's really,
really pretty this morning.
It's important to realize and remember
that these trees have been
living for thousands of years
and they've dealt with
pretty severe events,
fires and droughts in the past,
and they're amazingly resilient.
One of the things that
really is remarkable
about these trees is their ability
to recover from drought-type events.
The question is, as conditions change,
as temperatures continue
to increase globally,
are conditions gonna change to a point
where they may reach some threshold
where they're not able to recover
from these type of events.
(dramatic music)
It's an absolutely
amazing, unique experience
to be able to climb into these trees.
We want to preserve them.
We want them to be here and we want them
to be healthy and happy.
(dinging)